[Musica]
parliamo di soldi
soldi che ci tirano soldi che ci
condizionano
soldi che non fanno proprio pensare a un
incondizionato amore per l'umanità
scena prima
quindici anni fa una notte fredda
d'inverno alla fine di una partita di
calcetto in uno spogliatoio si avvicina
a Francesco e mi dice
Alessandro Ho un problema con con il
mutuo casa perché i tassi di interesse
sono schizzati in alto e la mia rata è
quasi raddoppiata che posso fare
E sì perché Francesco era una delle
tantissime persone che in quel momento
si trovava in una situazione molto
difficile una situazione che però per
essere compresa ci costringe a fare
qualche altro passo indietro Diciamo 20
25 anni
Forse avete visto qualcuno di voi ha
visto Nove settimane e mezzo un film
famoso per tante cose magari meno per
quello che sto citando a un certo punto
lei chiede a lui che lavoro fai e lui
risponde Faccio soldi coi soldi e il
1986 e Hollywood si comincia a rendere
conto che qualcosa di Profondo sta
cambiando nel mondo nella economia nella
società nella Finanza L'anno dopo Oliver
Stone produce Wall Street un film nel
quale un indimenticabile Michael Douglas
interpreta Gordon Checco l'icona dello
speculatore finanziario
per alcuni un mito per altri un mostro
Gordon Checco che al suo pupillo dice il
denaro non dorme mai ecco
fare soldi coi soldi e il denaro che non
dorme mai diventerà il mantra dei
decenni successivi
diventeranno ciò che genererà una
progressiva egemonia della finanza su
tutto il resto il denaro diventa il
centro delle nostre nostre scelte
individuali o collettive
si parla di finanziarizzazione una
brutta parola per appunto rappresentare
questo ruolo centrale della finanza e
quindi il denaro deve fare altro denaro
semplicemente girando su se stesso
questo alimenta una una crescita di
un'attività umana che è sempre esistita
che si chiama speculazione cercare di
guadagnare con operazioni di Commodo
nulla di male in sé Se non rispetta le
proporzioni che questo fenomeno prende
quando diciamo più o meno io e Francesco
parliamo in quella notte lì la misura
della speculazione sui mercati
finanziari è arrivata ad essere 70 volte
il prodotto interno lordo mondiale Che
vuol dire vuol dire che per ogni dollaro
per ogni euro che girava a quel tempo in
attività umana in produzione di beni in
produzione di servizi in scambi
commerciali ce ne erano 70 che giravano
per fare soldi coi soldi e questo ha
generato una bolla una bolla enorme che
a un certo punto esplosa è arrivata la
grande crisi finanziaria e questa Bolla
ha travolto le persone come Francesco le
imprese che sono andate in crisi le
banche Qualcuno ha fallito e qualcuna è
dovuta correre a dei soccorsi ma anche i
governi che nel frattempo si erano
indebitati troppo
e la politica si rende conto che non si
può più andare avanti così bisogna
cambiare le regole Bisogna rimettere
Main Street al centro rispetto a Wall
Street dice un Obama appena eletto
poi la grande crisi finanziaria si
trasferisce all'economia arriva la
recessione arriva la necessità di
sostenere questi Stati che che non
avevano più soldi per pagare il loro
debito Qualcuno dice Whatever it takes e
i mercati vengono di nuovo inondati di
denaro e il costo dell'interesse scende
tantissimo e fare prestiti non è più
conveniente quindi ci sono tanti soldi
in giro ma nessuno che fa credito tanti
soldi in giro che non sanno dove andare
e di nuovo si alimenta la speculazione
questa volta con una novità Grazie
all'intelligenza artificiale Questa
volta la speculazione cresce grazie a i
cosiddetti High frequency Trading cioè
scambi simultanee gli istantanei che
avvengono in poche frazioni di secondo
mentre io Batto un ciglio ci sono 10.000
scambi più o meno compro vendo compro
vendo per fare profitto tutto questo
oggi crea un volume che è tornato
complessivamente ad essere quello del
2007-2008 e che però per la metà o anche
di più è rappresentato da questi micro
scambi
poi arriva la pandemia
poi arriva la guerra
arriva l'inflazione
aumentano di nuovo i tassi di interesse
seconda scena
quella volta con Francesco riuscimmo a
intervenire andando in banca e chiedemmo
di modificare il contratto di mutuo
passando da tasso variabile a tasso
fisso e Francesco si rasserenò la sua
famiglia si rasserenò ogni mese ho
questa rata da pagare so qual è ci
faccio i conti ci sto dentro
dopo un anno che Questo era accaduto più
o meno ci rincontrammo su un campo di
calcetto e mentre tiravamo calcia una
palla per scaldarci Francesco si
avvicina e mi dice Senti Alessandro ho
visto che i tassi di interesse stanno
scendendo e che si prevede che
continuare a scendere che ne dici se
Ricambio il mutuo a tasso variabile
perché questo è quello che c'è successo
a tutti il nostro immaginario è stato
colonizzato da Gordon geco oggi pensiamo
tutti di poter fare un po' gli
speculatori finanziari pensiamo di poter
cavalcare quest'onda che è quella dei
mercati finanziari non ricordando che i
mercati sono un casinò e al casinò il
banco vince sempre e che quando ti siedi
a giocare a poker con qualcuno e quel
qualcuno ha tanti più soldi di te la
probabilità che lui vinca è molto alta e
i mercati finanziari hanno tanti più
soldi di noi allora abbiamo un grande
tema di cultura e di consapevolezza
dobbiamo smontare questo questa
colonizzazione che c'è stata nel nostro
immaginario e ricostruirne una diversa
ricostruirne una in cui non sia il
denaro il centro ma tornino essere le
persone il benessere delle persone e
l'ambiente e però dobbiamo domandarci
Come si può fare Beh in modo piccolo c'è
per iniziare
ogni volta che usiamo i soldi per pagare
con una carta con una app per chiedere
un prestito Quando ne abbiamo bisogno
per risparmiare se ci riusciamo
mettendoli in un conto corrente in un
conto deposito in una in uno strumento
finanziario Ecco ogni volta che facciamo
una scelta per quanto piccola per quanto
noi sembri infinitesimale rispetto alle
dimensioni dei mercati Noi possiamo
scegliere dove indirizzare i nostri
soldi e possiamo domandarci se lì dove
li ho messi
saranno soldi che mentre io non dormo
faranno cose che a me non piacciono cosa
faranno verso le persone cosa faranno
verso l'ambiente Quante piroette faranno
prima di andare dove io mi aspetto che
vadano ne faranno 10 30 50 70
Esistono delle alternative Esistono
delle banche cooperative degli operatori
di Finanza etica degli intermediari di
Finanza sostenibile cioè soggetti che
dicono che si impegnano a usare il
denaro solo secondo certi obiettivi
diciamo sociali ambientali e allora
bisogna occuparsene e qui veniamo
chiamate in causa tutti perché occuparsi
di soldi è noioso è triste è un po'
anche tecnicamente fastidioso ci fa
sentire inadeguati eppure partendo da
questo ognuno di noi può attivare un
cambiamento quindi occupiamoci dei
nostri soldi occupiamoci di dove li
mettiamo verifichiamo che chi ci ha
promesso certe scelte le mantenga e in
questo facendo questo compiamo un atto
civico un atto di interesse verso noi
stessi e direi anche un atto di amore
incondizionato verso l'umanità Grazie
[Applauso]